alors ces deux maladies qui touchent 100
mille personnes à peu près en france
pour l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de
traitement voilà assez c'est assez
compliqué daniel devaud gens très ému
forcément parce que votre maman elle est
un peu dans ce cas là a été pris en
charge maintenant une tendance non n'est
toujours pas être compliqué en fait et
je voulais vraiment remercier lycée moon
parce que c'est une maladie on est on
est tellement seule et démunie face à
salé du coup je me suis sentie moins
seule en le regardant
parce que on s'énerve face à des gens
comme ça quand ils ne m'auraient pas de
15 fois les mêmes choses et je vois que
c'est humain puisque lui aussi à la même
chose l'agressivité je la connais aussi
donc vraiment c'est un téléfilm utiliser
un documentaire pardon très utile
et ouais c'est ça c'est de la grande
solitude qu'on peut avoir face à ça et
je soutiens on parle d'un pudeur et tout
ça merci d'avoir il ya deux ans mais est
ce que ça dit bon on vivait tous la même
chose à différents degrés moi j'ai
rencontré une personne qui était dans
cet état là c'est vrai que le passé deux
étapes plutôt sympathique à très
agressif où elle ne se rappelle plus de
rien connaissent trénet
c'était ce que je voulais dire si ce qui
est beau c'est vraiment et moi je le vis
et l'humour c'est ce qui reste quand on
a tout oublié
il faut vraiment jouer cette carte de
l'humour parce que parce que ma maman
souvient de presque rien et il a de la
chance et 10 passes que son papa se
souvient de sa maman moi ma maman ce fut
la même plutôt intel a tellement aimé
c'était le summum de sa vie là bas se
souvient même que quand tu montes toile
il faut tous donc voilà il ya des
habitués mais ça m'a fait du bien quand
même de voir ce set face à ces deux
clients ter merci ellis mans